who are the most oppressed people in the
world could it be christians in the
middle east
child slaves in sudan yeah they're
oppressed but the world's
most depressed person is right in this
country it's michelle obama
how oppressed is michelle obama she's so
impressed she told us recently she's
afraid to get her driver's license
renewed
she's terrified at the whole foods in
martha's vineyard
many of us still live in fear as we go
to the grocery store or
worry about our dogs walking our dogs or
allowing our children to get a license i
like so many parents black kids have to
that the the innocent act of getting a
license
puts fear in our hearts
yeah she's afraid to get a license
michelle obama cares deeply about racism
it's kind of the focus of her life
sort of weird given that that she
doesn't seem worried at all or even
aware
of the rise in targeted attacks against
asian americans and there have been a
lot of them
just this week an 80 year old asian man
was brutally beaten in the state of
california on tape you may have seen it
the suspects have been arrested
the interesting thing is that probably
not white supremacists one of them was
only 11 years old
you never hear michelle obama mention
attacks like this why is that it seems
like the one thing she won't talk about
ying ma is happy to talk about it she's
the author of chinese girl in the ghetto
she joins us tonight yeah thanks so much
for coming on
so all of us are seeing this if you're
concerned about
racism and i noticed the bite
administration announced today that the
single greatest threat we face is white
supremacy
single greatest threat why doesn't
michelle obama ever mention what the
rest of us
are watching well it's not just
michelle obama it's the biden
administration it's
most of our political leaders um even
though
far too many of the horrific attacks
against asian americans happening
practically every other day now far too
many of those attacks are perpetrated by
black perpetrators our leaders simply
are afraid to utter the word black
what we need in this country is an
uncomfortable but honest
national conversation about the
prevalence of
black crimes in general and
black on asian violence in particular
now what we actually could benefit a lot
from
is the leadership of black role models
like president obama like black leaders
at the black in black churches across
the country
we need leaders to come out and denounce
black on asian violence unequivocally
and i you know i was a big fan of
president obama when he bluntly
talked about fatherless black households
back in 2008
that took courage and that took honesty
and leadership and i do hope
that he will display the same kind of
courage
and leadership on this particular issue
especially given that
president obama grew up in asia in
indonesia
and what we need is that we need leaders
like that to call on the black community
to engage in some
serious soul-searching to actually go
out and tell its community that these
attacks are heinous they're despicable
they're disgusting and that it's not
okay
we need that honest conversation there
is great friendship between blacks and
asians in this country and so at this
point
we are calling on our friends in the
black community
to please help to please display some
leadership on this
issue because what is going on is simply
not
acceptable and there are far too few
leaders who are willing to even utter
the word black when describing these
crimes that we see
on video far too often
that seems reasonable and honest and
measured to me i appreciate it
thank you thank you tucker
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else